it is time for drew's news your good
news mama bird feeding you that good
news worm
we're starting with the beautiful issue
of people magazine everybody gets so
excited with that
and guess what oh look yeah it's none
other than dame helen mirren um there's
also a really special story inside that
continues to celebrate women um it gives
a little inside look into the favorite
besties for all of us oprah and gail
they're finally telling
their origin story of the beautiful
friendship that we've all come to know
as that's my gale
it all started 46 years ago on a snowy
night in baltimore oprah was 21 gayle
was 22 and the two young newsies were
following their dreams at wjtz
tv
and then this blizzard hit and oprah
invited gail over and they were like up
all night chatting they had this great
kind of evening that the weather brought
them together and the rest is history
you just never know when you're going to
meet your next bestie you know i've met
besties poolside i've met him at a bar
i've met him at this very desk right
here
you never know when you're going to need
a bedroom think about that who could you
meet next and they could be your next
best friend i love that idea
there's a food innovation that you can
try out right now just across the river
in jersey city fox business reports that
the newport center mall has just
installed a hamburger vending machine
it's called roboburger
and it cooks up fresh burgers made to
order in just six minutes the robot
grills your patty toasts your bun and
then squirts your burger with some
condiments
ross yes thought well you know there are
inventions where you always remember
where you were the first time you heard
about them this is one of those
inventions
robo burger welcome to the family and i
say this is somebody who worked at
mcdonald's i talk about it proudly here
i know how to assemble a hamburger
triple threat triple threat register
drive through and grill thank you very
much
and so i'm watching that were you guys
watching that robo do its thing on there
i like your technique robo you know how
to make a burger i would eat one of
these they so imagine this it's like
frozen patties in there they're grilling
them to your specifications how you want
it would you try a robo burger i would i
like and i like burgers occasionally and
i like veggie burgers so i hope they
have both options because i'm a super
flexitarian
get ready for this oh i'm ready okay
it's the queen's platinum jubilee year
and that's 70 years on the throne um i
feel like we've been hearing about this
but these new details are going to blow
your mind all right digital spy reports
that for the first time ever the jubilee
will be televised and it's going to be
hosted by an epic duo you guys i can't
even believe i'm about to say these two
names okay are you ready for the two
names yes tom cruise and helen mirren
why right
where did they
what was that
yes it's going to be a huge star-studded
affair complete with military and
equestrian displays a 75-piece orchestra
a huge theater
uh done in four acts traveling through
royal history starting with the reign of
the queen elizabeth uh the first played
of course by helen mirren this is a play
that's going to be put on
this is this is insane
this is what we call a dream come true
all right break out the fine chyna get
me some tea and crumpets and do not
bother me until the jubilee is over we
all turn to friends for relationship
advice but experts say their advice is
possibly bad
pop sugar reports that according to a
dating app survey 54 of gen z singles
regret taking their friends advice
experts say your friend's advice is
questionable at best because number one
they can be projecting their own
relationship stuff onto you which may
not be for you and number two you might
have different wants needs and desires
for a relationship that maybe they can't
understand ross thought well that's a
really nice way to say maybe your friend
is a mess and you shouldn't listen to
them
i think right like it
it depends on the friends
we all have the friends who like you go
to for advice about relationships and
then we have the friends you go to for
advice about tequila you know there's
like different
areas of expertise
[Applause]
[Music]